hello reject nation loki episode
6 finale reaction today part one of our
reaction to be specific now look i
normally rush through these intros
because the watch time is everything on
youtube watch time is everything
i know a lot of guys skip it but i just
want to take a moment to be sincere
sincere a moment uh
to say thank you to everyone who has
been watching loki with us
or checking out our reactions uh you
know since the first episode and
everyone's been watching us since way
back with like the one division times
and of course before that too but
this year marvel's been just freaking
incredible it's like when we do these
reactions
from my end the whole goal that we ever
really have
whatever thoughts and feelings that we
normally reserve
are a little too insecure to express
around other people random jokes that
pop into our head that we keep to
ourselves the whole point is just to let
it out here
so thank you for to everyone who's just
been well i was just to just be
our vulnerable selves it's a weird thing
to be thankful for but uh
i'm very much grateful for it thank you
to john for being alongside with me this
whole time for many years this channel
was
mainly me and a bunch of guests and to
have you as my partner for so long i
could not do these late nights without
you buddy so thank you i want to thank
everyone
who has been at our patreon page and has
joined because of this show
and for just the patreon in general you
guys have gotten us through some really
tough times
i want to thank pritham jindal for
editing these highlights for us and for
the heck of it eric and
right now chronic 2 for one division and
falcon winter soldier because
you guys really hustle yeah you work
with me so well on whatever notes i have
we're in a position now because of you
guys the subscribers supporters of the
real rejects of where we can
actually get some help now with some of
the edits it's been such a journey and
couldn't be here without you guys
so sincerely thank you as far as another
reaction channel to shout out i'll shout
him out
right when the reaction is done
[Music]
the timekeepers are all the stand
between us and full scale calamity
always they focus on the on the pen yeah
oh my god we're gonna be king to conquer
king loki miss minutes
they're all in there i'm telling you
it's just stan lee
that's it way to go dick
[Music]
what's going on the whole is all of time
all of the marvel time i've been
affected
oh those breakdown videos are gonna go
bananas so many sound clips
for the right to experience
wow
[Music]
wow
oh that was
crazy oh i'm gonna miss this show so
much
wow
my heart's racing
god this is gorgeous
[Music]
oh you're gonna tell me not to kick the
door in that made a difference
well if you think it's a bad idea i'd
prefer you to split your mind
no nothing to say everything okay
yeah i just need a moment
she's waiting a long time for this okay
shut up
i was pruned before you even existed i
have been waiting for this moment my
entire life
i just need a second to get my head
straight okay sure
of course
you don't have a second
damn this looks like saruman the white's
cast no
welcome to the citadel at the end of
time
come on congratulations y'all had an
awfully long journey to get here he's
impressed
he who's impressed he who remains
he who remains
he created all and he controls all
at the end it is only he who remains
oh he wants to offer you a deal
he's worked it out so we can reinsert
both of y'all back
into the timeline in a way that won't
disrupt things
and disrupt things the tva can keep
doing its vital work
and y'all can live the lives you've
always wanted
and what have we always wanted now don't
play coy with me
mister how you got into this
mess what the battle of new york silly
you versus those self-righteous avengers
how would you like to win yep
yep you can kill thanos you want the
infinity gauntlet
yours oh my gosh dude
no problem another bargain what about
you missy
all those years on the run how would you
like to wake up tomorrow with
just a lifetime of happy memories
two loki's in the same place oh wow
[Music]
together on the timeline
it's crazy but he could make it work
don't do it maybe do it for a little bit
but don't do it
entertain it and you can have it all
together
it's fiction we write our own destiny
now
oh sure you do good luck with that
oh golly sinister miss minutes yeah
the mouthpiece her clock reads 666
[Music]
hey there what took you so long sorry
some things had to get worked out
she's a sinister clock this isn't what i
asked for
i know but he thinks this will be more
useful
who happy readings wow
she is revealing her true orange color
here who remains not for much longer but
who is he
really
great shot
does look like timekeeper statues yeah
what if it's a watcher
i love how everything's got that
consuming gold
gold-filled cracks look
oh my god let's get this reveal go
[Music]
the elevator sound yeah
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
oh they did it this is wild this is
wild the two of you same person
i mean it's it's a little unnatural
but
wow
he who remains he will revenge
she's still calling me out creepy right
right
i like it
come on let's talk from my office
wow we have him here not what you're
expecting
so many trio elevator shots in this show
just a man flesh and blood don't tell me
i'm a disappointment
just a little bit easier to
wow
kill
[Music]
i don't care we were wrong this is
awesome yeah
damn it's all about the execution we
should have stuck true to it came up
after episode 4.
dang it
looks like the sanctum satoru please
take a seat
loki
okay
let's make an espresso i said i wasn't
to be disturbed
well you're not gonna be happy to see me
huh
he's back if anyone was ever gonna make
it back from the board i suppose it was
going to be you
oh well you know one man's void is
another man's piece of cake
so you're going to prune me i like that
idea but you know my standards might be
a little bit higher in that area than
yours you know with close personal
friends i'm sorry
oh i couldn't let you get in the way of
our mission
mission timekeepers are fake we're all
variants what
mission it can't have been for nothing
that's why i had to prune you
190 to my office immediately yeah sorry
that's not going to work out the way you
think it is now that we know your secret
what did you do
[Music]
we went to high school
[Music]
the pen paid off stand down b-15
you need to listen to me there'll be
time for that just wait
what the hell is going on here oh great
way
who are you and what the hell are you
doing in my school
that isn't judge ren slayer we have a
lot to talk about
damn waking up all the minute man i'm
not sure you quite understand the
situation
you've lost we found you
so we're still doing that let's get all
this out of the way
you can't kill me because
i already know what's going to happen
see
so twisted no
it's because of that little ten pad you
have there right
but how do i already have it loaded up
with everything i need to know
to keep from being killed by youtube
i know it all and i've seen it all
everything you guys did on the mentos i
saw
all the stuff the tva didn't know about
i knew
all the talking that
little look by the lake
quite sentimental very touching stuff by
the way no we broke out of your little
game
that's how we got here no wrong
every step you took to get here
i paved the road
he just walked down oh
wow wow
[Music]
there's only one way this can go then
why are we here
come on no you can't get to the end
until you've been
changed by the journey this stuff
it needs to happen to get us all in the
in the right
mindset to finish the quest
right right so it's all a game it's all
a manipulation interesting that your
head
would go to that
selby you think you can trust this guy
don't listen to him don't listen to him
do you think you're
even capable of trusting anyone at all
[Music]
no you know what had happened if we
didn't prune the timeline
chaos death free will
free will only one person gets free will
the one in charge no
friends across time allies
to the end shut up that was so beautiful
and then you sent me to die
i didn't change you didn't change you
betrayed me no no you
betrayed me i looked out for you hung my
neck out for you
and you suffer a crisis of faith and
turn to those variants
beyond the friendship and you threw it
all away on a couple of loki's
no mobius i didn't betray you are you
doing
what i need to do wait stop look maybe
we can build this into something better
together i'm sorry numbers
i'm not gonna let you go
please mobius even with that you're of
no danger to me
is that what you
[Music]
yep think right
where are you gonna go in search of free
will
the only one who has free will is the
one in charge that's the end of part one
people you can click this end screen
card link
description box and pin comment to go
watch part two
and we got a pretty lengthy uh spoiler
review
you know there's a lot there's a lot you
know whoa
[Music]
talking